muchas
y tus ojos
ya está
al segundo
ahí
donde planeas
al estudiar
al queda
de igual verdad
cuántos dijo 2 direct
cuenta de empresa
cuando el país
y bajas del gobernador
soy diputado
o agricultor
strauss
ingeniero
nuevo
vuelve
vuelve alta
como vas
ya llegar
yo les digo el volcán
y es que de esto se trata la vida
desde siempre está
buscan
muchos
buscamos el camino
la conducta
al destino
y ya planeamos
otros
vamos
descubriendo
de qué va la vida
un importado del primero
o el segun
lo que importa
es estás
de bután
sí
importa lo que vals al cels
pero él saben lo que realmente importa
es
qué estás haciendo
cuando me invitaron
por segunda vez
a vivir
mi sueño
y yo dije guau
net
el leal
distinto
cuando usted
a dónde va
cuando sabes cuál es tu plan de vida
automáticamente los caminos se dan
y yo es último y pasión
un día dije 20
con faces
tenía 12 años
no sabía que realmente hacía un
conferida ni el compromiso
al ser yo como periodista
pero yo dije bolt
para ello
siete años después
estoy
como louis
o no
solo una vez
quiero dar una conferencia
uy
louis
gusto tanto cree una mal
una vida las adversidades
se pueden quebrar
hoy tú verás puedes ahora
en el secundario
me apodaron 'el chueco'
en plena adolescencia
donde yo estaba buscando que iba a hacer
sin aceptar
mi discapacidad
y un gritan realmente gran hombre viene
y brigitte
se apodere el fuego
genial
me ha dado mi mal
y es ahí cuando descubrí
cómo
gestionas la adversidad
y yo las he convertido en la oportunidad
y entonces empecé
que tenía una idea que es compatible con
ella
y dkv
y un día me
avn
a emprender
ya tengo un hogar
ya tengo un producto
y sí
más y más
pasa que del simón qué vamos a hacer
pero no algo que vamos desde los
guardamos
debajo del cajón
donde cada noche no nos acordamos
legítimo que lo íbamos darle
a la mañana siguiente la rutina del
órgano
y dicen algo al pedo
el cuadro
qué pasaría
y la rutina
y convirtiera en eso están
nunca agrega
el momento perfecto
ni las bendiciones perfectas
el momento es ahora
hizo falta una cosa
en footing
al 100
y todo lo que sabes
que a veces no tenemos nada
ni dinero
de apoyo
mi papá
mi papá fue
a los miles de años
justamente cuando mal
clones
i
y no tu verdad
solo
un sueño
y cuando supe para dónde iba
los caminos salieron todo campo
porque es es gasolina expansión de
energía
que hace que trabaje el día de noche
para llegar
a dónde te han entrado
pero siempre ella casting vas a llegar a
creer
de txingas la rodilla
hidratadas
y es tan normal
se acuerda
es casi obligatorio
y agost
y me daba tanto miedo
después de displays 23 se convirtió en
mi deporte favorito
y sé el porqué
todo que no se ofrece
si se aprende
cuando el cervical
te crees
cuando se trata de evolucionar
el fondo es heridas
las que hacen más fuerte
al guerrero
y hay una gran salida cuando crees que
todo se ha perdido
tan simple como
vuelve a donde el pelo
si no te digamos nada
porque no me planta
es del todo
vuelve a repetir el proceso
cuántas veces jr
wayne
en verde
als
el xerez ha experimentado
con lo que tiene
y a esto que a esto que tienes agregarle
algo
que siempre va a llevar la receta
qué pasión
estudia
cuantas veces sea en el daño
y si está bien una caldera
quien realmente ha descubierto
una lesión
central de un título universitario
en mi caso no
en un caso que a emprender las
competencias
y piedad
y mejor
y tienes que parar
pero
todo el tiempo por los siglos de los
siglos
paz
calentamos tanto los proyectos
enojado
y cuando ya estaba a punto de usted
ha ido una crisis no mañana
y si me dicen que no pues ya que te
digan que no
total de óvulos
hoy no ha llegado todavía
y vuelves
y lo que realmente importa
y lo que hace
lo que soñaste
en salta a girar secundaria
el fuego que estoy haciendo ocurrida
hace unos minutos
el reducto moderno
si la gente
monetizar su pasión
y capitalizará tus talentos
este mundo a mantenerse allí
con un artista verdad
- su versión
más
alto
y es eso
deja de pensar
y empieza a actuar
y en realidad
somos uno que hacemos
no lo que es
llevamos 20
bernal
qué
al sol
de la parálisis
entienden yo entendí mi palabra cerebral
como moneda de cambio
como boleto
a la acción